is human existence absurd and if it is
what sort of stance should we take is is
there any reasonable stance to take
is there any sort of moral imperative
that would drive us towards one thing
away from another thing
can we have any kind of ethic or at
least an ethos in
a universe that we feel to be hostile to
be
out of sync with their own
needs desires wishes
well that's the question that camus is
dealing with in the method synthesis and
this is the second installation a lot of
what we've been doing so far seems to be
preliminary work now we're actually
getting into the real heart of the work
we're not yet going to talk about
syphilisis the mythical character and
what he represents for kamu because that
comes near the end of the work
what we're going to talk about today
are intellectual responses to the
problem of the absurd
and some of camus criticisms of the
people that he's calling existentialists
he actually didn't like the title of
existentialist but he fits within their
spectrum as we'll see
and then we're going to look at what he
calls an ethics of quantity
and we'll look at a few representatives
of that so
let's think before we actually start
going back into the text about this this
quote
the absurd is born of this confrontation
between the human need
and the unreasonable silence of the
world
so we have what he calls three
characters of this this primordial drama
that's going on
that has become unavoidable in modern
times
it could be avoided
before although a lot of people grasped
in his view
the meaninglessness of things
but now it's become for anybody who
really thinks according to kamu again
unavoidable
so the absurd
the absurd has really three parts to it
and if you take any one of those parts
out you're not going to have the absurd
so it's not that the world by itself is
absurd as he says
if you want to call the world absurd
you're actually
misrepresenting things the world is
irrational
the world is unreasonable
and what does that mean it's not aligned
with human beings
and we looked at a lot of different ways
in which absurdity manifests itself even
within human beings but
this is one term one pole the
unreasonable silence of the world or the
irrational world
here's another term the human need
or human nostalgia as he'll call it
a sense of the world
or existence or even the human being
within themselves being tailored to
what it is that we desire and what it is
that we can know and understand
those are two polls
but there has to be this confrontation
in order for you to have the absurd
there has to be the sense of a
discrepancy of a discordance of things
not actually
lining up the way that they should
or you don't have the full
sense the full concept of the absurd
a little bit later
he'll call the absurd lucid reason
noting its limits and reason is what
makes us particularly human as well as
desiring laughing
having
certain kinds of societies and all that
sort of stuff but reason is something
that's really distinctively human
lucid reason noting its limits
is one thing about the absurd
he also talks about the absurd man
learning to live without appeal that's
camus ideal that's his view about how we
should handle this but we'll get into
that in a moment first we want to
take a look at how the problem
manifests itself in the life of the mind
so we started out last time by looking
at the general concept of the absurd and
we mentioned a little bit about the life
of the mind this time we're actually
going right into the passages where kamu
is talking about this
so he starts off by saying
the mind's first step is to distinguish
what is true from what is false
okay that's very basic you can see that
in aristotle you can see that in plato
uh saint anselm for example says the
whole purpose of human reason is to
distinguish the truth from the false the
good from the evil the just from the
unjust you know being able to make these
sort of distinctions
is that all that goes on though
he says however as soon as thought
reflects on itself
what it first discovers is a
contradiction
so
contradiction
is one of our primordial
experiences of reflection
it doesn't mean that it's our primordial
experience in the world but as soon as
we start thinking about the world as
soon as we start thinking
about ourselves as being in the world as
soon as we start thinking about our own
thinking about the world and other
people's thinking about the world we see
contradictions arise
so he says
over the centuries no one has furnished
a clearer and more elegant demonstration
of the business than aristotle he talks
about the the
fact that if you're going to assert
something is true you're also asserting
that your assertion is true and you know
vice versa with falsity
and he says that this vicious circle is
but the first in a series in which the
mind that studies itself gets lost in a
giddy whirling
see the thing is once you start
reflecting
the common theme among existentialists
once you start reflecting
you can always reflect again
you can always raise it to a higher
level you can always continue the
process you can iterate it as they say
so he says the very simplicity of these
paradoxes is what
causes problems for us
so the mind's deepest desire even in its
most elaborate operations parallels
man's unconscious feeling in the face of
his universe
what is it that we want
what is it that our minds and our hearts
truly
desire he says it's an insistence upon
familiarity and appetite for clarity so
what we're imposing on the world
like it or not consciously or not
we want the world to make sense to us
and you know that means a lot of
different things we don't have to go
into that in great depth at this point
but we do want it to make sense to us we
want it to be
answerable to us
understanding the world for a man is
reducing it to the human stamping it
with his seal he says
so
like
other things
we
change our environment to suit us
but we do so mentally as well
do we falsify it that way are we
ignoring important features of reality
by doing so you can ask
so he says likewise the mind that aims
to understand reality can consider
itself satisfied only by reducing it to
terms of thought if man realized that
the universe like him this is really
interesting
the universe cannot just think
given this if it's to be familiar the
universe like him can love
and suffer
then man would be reconciled then the
human being would be at home in the
world
if thought discovered in the shimmering
mirrors of phenomena eternal relations
capable of summing them up and summing
themselves up in a single principle
then would be seen in intellectual joy
of which the myth of the blessed would
be much a ridiculous imitation if the
mind could truly discover
reality
and
make sense of it in such a way that it
could be laid out in say axioms or
principles or some sort of systematic
comprehensible unity
then we would actually be happy
and he calls this a nostalgia for unity
an appetite for the absolute
and he says this illustrates the
essential impulse of the human drama so
what do we have here this is a
human need or desire that's trying to
impose itself
on the world and what does the world
give back
it doesn't fit our categories it doesn't
fit
the way in which we want it to be it
doesn't satisfy our desires
we want it to be and that's what he
calls nostalgia
so he says it's essential to consider as
a constant point of reference in this
essay the regular hiatus the
gap the rupture
between
what we fancy we know and what we really
know practical ascent and simulated
ignorance which allows us to live with
ideas which if we really put them to the
test
watch upset our whole life
so if we really start thinking about
things if we actually start following
through and asking ourselves you know
the kind of questions that philosophers
have done especially in the modern
period saying not just
what's going on here or what is the
world or what are its principles but do
i actually know
whether these are the right principles
do i actually know whether the mind or
the soul and the world link up together
and map on to each other
if we start thinking in the way
cartesians do or lock-ins do or humans
do or conscience do
then we're putting ourselves at risk for
being
profoundly unhappy
but
we're also doing something that
satisfies
a human need a human need to know to try
to attain certainty
so he says can we do this no
we must despair of ever reconstructing
the familiar calm surface which would
give us peace of heart
after so many centuries of inquiries so
many applications among thinkers we are
well aware that this is true for all
knowledge
with the exception of professional
rationalists but i guess you know
certain philosophy professors and people
in other fields where they believe that
they have certain knowledge
today people despair of true knowledge
of whom and what indeed can i say i know
that
this heart within me i can feel come who
says
and i judge that it exists
that's an interesting point this is his
cartesian kojito by the way
i feel
therefore i exist not i think therefore
i exist
i feel therefore i exist
there ends all my knowledge and the rest
is construction for if i try to seize
this self of which i feel sure if i try
to define and summarize it it's nothing
but water slipping through my fingers he
says
this very heart of mind
this very heart which is mine will
forever remain indefinable to me
between the certainty i have of my own
existence and the content i try to give
to that assurance the gap will never be
filled
so camus was saying you know look in
late modernity after all these projects
these philosophical attempts have failed
we can have the cartesian starting point
of wanting to have complete you know
certainty something that's unshakable
our own existence
but we can't get much beyond that
we can't be sure about
what what's what's there
what about the world he says i know
things in the world
yet all the knowledge on earth will give
me nothing to assure that this world is
mine
it will it won't give me
meaning it won't put all these parts
together in a way that makes it map on
to my needs my desires my wishes
you describe it to me and you teach me
to classify it you enumerate as laws and
in my thirst for knowledge i admit that
they're true these are all ways of
knowing the world right
you take apart its mechanism my hope
increases
at the final stage you teach me this
wondrous and multicolored universe can
be reduced to the atom
and the atom itself can be reduced to
the electron
but eventually
what are we left with
things that don't seem anything like the
world that we wanted to understand
so he says to will to to think
to the desire is to stir up paradoxes
so what's the conclusion of this
he says the intelligence tells me in its
way this world is absurd
it's contrary blind reason
may well claim that all is clear
i was waiting for proof and longing for
it to be right
now he's he's referring to a distinction
here that that actually arises
in late antiquity and runs through the
middle ages and you see it in a lot of
neoplatonic literature
between
the intellect or intelligence and reason
and reason in this case is understood as
being
fairly mechanically
structured
deductive
it can also be inductive in some sense
but it works with principles and then it
deduces from them and you know maps
everything into concepts
and structures and organizes knowledge
then there's intelligence which is
something higher something a bit more
fluid something that can take a more
comprehensive grass reason
in the way that he's using it here
reason is not able to get a good view of
itself
intelligence is able to
see itself and actually know whether it
is measuring up to its own standards or
not
it can see its limitations
and so the intelligence would be in some
sense higher than reason
so he says the intelligence tells me
that the world is absurd it's contrary
blind reason may well claim that this is
clear
but blind reason is actually sort of
getting things wrong
so let's go on
we talked about absurdity becoming uh
something like a passion
and
we talked a little bit in the last time
about the existentialist philosophers
that camus
is interested in
engaging
and is going to criticize as ultimately
taking the wrong
position
from this problem
because you know what are your options
here
well we talked about one option which
was rationalism right there you say
no the world isn't absurd i'm going to
ignore that
the world is not unreasonable i'm going
to make it reasonable
or i'm going to pretend that it's
reasonable
or i'll only look at the parts that
actually fit you know
what i'm going to call reasonable or
rational
but if you're doing that
you're in a sense
aligning yourself if we want to put it
in terms of problems
what you're doing there is you're trying
to change the parameters of the problem
rather than actually addressing the
problem that you've been given
and you know you know it is if you're
taking a test
and you answer a question that hasn't
been asked
and you fail to answer the question that
you are being asked you flunk
well the same thing happens with the
rationalists
now another possibility
is you say yes
there is the absurd
reason can't
reconcile us to the world
and there is this discordance between
the the way the world is you can't even
talk about the world having its wishes
so much
and that our own needs wishes desires
do you just linger with that absurdity
then
do you live with it
or do you still try to get beyond it
trying to get beyond it is what caimu
calls the leap and that's what he sees
the existentialists that he's going to
criticize as doing so he talks about
jasper's heidegger kierkegaard
chest off dostoevsky
he talks about phenomenologists like
husserl talks about shaler and he says a
whole family of mines related by their
nostalgia
but opposed by their methods of their
aims have persisted in blocking the
royal road of reason and in recovering
the direct paths of truth so learning
about the world learning about the human
being
but what have they done there
um they started out from the
indescribable universe where
contradiction antinomy anguish and
impotence reigns okay so an unreasonable
world
but
what do they do after that they take
some sort of leap
they
don't really face up to the problem as
such they come up with a in camus view
wrong solution
so i'm actually going to skip over the
parts where he's talking about what
they're getting right in his view
and i'm going to
skip ahead
so he says
how can one fail to feel the basic
relationship of these minds the
phenomenologists and the existentialists
how can one fail to see that they take
their stand around a privileged and
bitter moment in which hope has no
further place i want everything to be
explained to me or nothing
and the reason is impotent when it hears
this cry from the heart
the mind aroused by this insistence
seeks and finds nothing but
contradictions and nonsense what i fail
to understand is nonsense the world is
peopled with such irrationals the world
itself whose single meaning i do not
understand is but a vast irrational
if one could say just once this is clear
all would be saved but these men vie
with each other
in proclaiming that nothing is clear all
is chaos that all man has is his
lucidity and his definitive knowledge of
the wall surrounding him
so he says all these experiences agree
and confirm each other the mind when it
reaches its limits must make a judgment
and choose its conclusions
so
what's it going to be then
this is where he starts talking about
philosophical suicide so he goes into
this section that's actually titled that
he says the feeling of the absurd is not
for all that the notion of the absurd
and we looked at the notion of the
absurd last time and we
looked at a bunch of different ways in
which we we can talk about the absurd
um
now like he says
if we want to look at the notion of the
absurd we can say that the word the
absurd is not in
man or human being as such
and it's not in the world as such
it's in their presence together
this is an important metaphysical
point that he's making here
camus thinks that you can't analyze
human nature
outside of the world in which human
beings are so you can't analyze human
nature first and then come back to the
world later on with way to say that
descartes did
likewise you can't just begin from the
world and then try to find man
in the world or the human being in the
world
you have to
begin from both poles which means that
you're always going to begin from
determinate situations you're never
going to be able to begin from human
being as such
the world has such
this is part of what makes him an
existentialist focus on concrete
experiences and situations
now what about absurdity itself
well he gives us a lot of ways of
thinking about or talking about
absurdity
and then he talks about
an absurd logic as well
he says carrying this absurd logic to
its conclusion i must admit that that
struggle implies a total absence of hope
which has nothing to do with despair a
continual rejection which what must not
be confused with renunciation and a
conscious dissatisfaction which must not
be compared to immature
unrest everything that destroys conjures
away or exercises these requirements and
to begin with consent which overthrows
divorce ruins the absurd and devalues
the attitude that may then be proposed
the absurd has meaning only in so far as
it has not agreed to
what's going on there
well this is where we need to erase some
of this
and
come clean about what camus is actually
doing here
he's elaborating
ethic
we saw earlier that one of the things
in the previous video
camus said that
if you're going to be consistent
if you're going to follow things through
if you're going to take a thought and
then actually make good on it so to
speak
then you're going to have to deal with
this problem that's going to come up the
problem of suicide what do you do in the
face of the absurd
now you could say to somebody well i
don't have to do that i don't have to
think about that
why should i bother
and then camus would have to come clean
and admit
there is this commitment
to
follow out
the thoughts
or conclusions
if the human being and the world
together
are absurd
what does that mean then
i mean you could you could escape that
just by you know turning on the tv and
watching that all the time or drinking
all the time or
you know seeking other stimulants
throwing yourself into all sorts of you
know love affairs or have sex all the
time or you know whatever what whatever
you can do to escape it
kamu would say that's that is just
escapism that's not actually facing up
to the full consequences of it but you
could say well why should i
and camus is committed to this this is
part of his ethics what else is part of
it
he talks about
struggle
and what does that
entail
total absence of hope
no hope and that's not despair
rejection
which is
not
renunciation
and
dissatisfaction
is not
immature
unrest
so this actually shows you where would
you be going wrong if you were just
engaging in escapism that would be
immature unrest
uh you're not rejecting the human being
the world and the absurdity that that is
produced by the fact that they don't
they don't link up with each other the
way they should
um by rejecting it you're not renouncing
it you're not saying ah it's all just
crap it's no good
you're not lapsing into pessimism or
quietism which is you know not doing
anything
not hoping is not the same thing for
camus as
just despairing
so this is this is pretty interesting
this requires some unpacking um
and we're going to get to this a bit and
we're going to get to see how this plays
itself out in a little while
when we talk about these different
orientations of the
adventurer
or
the
actor or you know these other these
other possibilities before that though
let's look at an intellectual
possibility existential philosophy the
way that camus understands it so he says
to limit myself to existential
philosophies i see that all of them
without exemption suggest
escape
so this is another thing
struggle
is
not escape
you're not
trying to
embrace the absurd only to jump beyond
it
says through an odd reasoning starting
out from the absurd over the ruins of
reason in a closed universe limit to the
human
to the human they deify what crushes
them and find reason to hope in what
impoverishes them this forced hope is
religious in all of them it deserves
attention so
canoe thinks that all these other
existentialists are actually
you might say
smuggling in religion by the back door
whatever they're going to call it their
their orientation is religious and it's
religious in a way
that
fits a kind of caricature of religion um
you know
which tertullian in the ancient uh
period
was a good representative by saying i
believe because it's absurd
so
we call this attitude often fidaism in
philosophy
and he says i shall merely analyze here
as a few as examples a few themes do uh
dear to chest off and kierkegaard and
then he says but i'm also going to talk
about jasper's
so what can we say about this well
jasper's carl josper's
he spends a lot of time trying to
show that you can't attain any sort of
transcendence
and then he says um
we can't plumb the depth of experience
we're in a universe upset by failure and
can we ask will he advance or at least
draw the conclusions from that failure
i mean what would the conclusions from
that failure be well we can't get beyond
this universe which does not seem to be
tailor made for us and
we you know it doesn't seem like there's
any sort of god doesn't seem like
there's any sort of reason animating it
no great world historical plan or
anything like that
what does the ospreys actually do
camus says without justification as he
says to himself he suddenly asserts all
at once the transcendent
the essence of experience and the
superhuman significance of life when he
writes
does not the failure reveal beyond any
possible explanation and interpretation
not the absence but the existence of
transcendence so
you know
if camus is right
then what's going on
is guys like jasper's
are
you know they're agreeing with him and
saying yeah everything is absurd
there's no transcendence and that's
precisely why there's transcendence
it's almost like that line is just so
crazy it might it's so crazy it just
might work
or the notion of like pulling yourself
up by your bootstraps that you know only
baron von munch housing can can actually
pull off
so
let's say you actually do buy that and
you go along that way what is the oscars
doing then
he says the absurd becomes god in the
broadest meaning of this word and that
inability to understand a god who's
incomprehensible
who's just sort of you know transcendent
in a way that we can't make any any
sense of or predict or any any
really even relate to
that inability to understand becomes the
existence that illuminates everything
nothing logically prepares this
reasoning
i can call it a leap
is that all that's going on in the
aspers i mean that's a different issue
that we can go into here
if kamu is right
well then this is just a leap
it's
it's pure
assertion
it's
saying to the absurd world well i desire
for there to be transcendent so that by
god there's going to be some
transcendence but then i'll call that
god
is that going to satisfy anybody
i mean it's certainly not going to be
like a proof of god's existence or
anything like that
but even think to yourself is there any
content there
does this make any difference in a
person's life
i would say no
and so you know camus is actually making
a very important criticism here
so you know jasper is is you know
doing this
like he says the more bitterly yaspers
destroys the reasons preconceptions the
more radically he will explain the world
explain the world in the sense of giving
meaning to a transcendent meaning
chest off is doing something similar he
says
chest off says stuff like we turn toward
god only to obtain the impossible as for
the possible men suffice
and camus says if there is a chestovian
philosophy it's difficult to say if
there is a chestovian philosophy because
chestoff was not a systematic thinker he
was a deliberately anti-systematic
thinker
says if there is a chestovian philosophy
i can say that it is altogether summed
up in this way for when at the
conclusion of his passionate analyses
chest off discovers the fundamental
absurdity of all existence he does not
say this is the absurd but rather this
is god we must rely on him even if he
does not correspond to any of our
rational categories so that confusion
may not be possible the russian
philosopher even hints that this god may
be full of hatred and hateful
incomprehensible and contradictory but
the more hideous is his face the more he
asserts his power his greatness is his
incoherence so that's what kamu is
saying
chest off is is doing in his philosophy
so chest off is going even further in
some respects than the neospurs
so he says for chest off acceptance of
the absurd is contemporaries
contemporaneous with the absurd itself
being aware of it amounts to accepting
it
and the whole logical effort of his
thought is to bring it out so at the
same time the tremendous hope it
involves may burst forth
here's where camus says something really
interesting
he says let me repeat that this attitude
is legitimate
so camus is an atheist
he's rejecting jaspers he's rejecting
chest off
and their religiously based philosophies
as relying on some sort of you know
faith commitment
that has no rational
preparation grounding anything like that
and yet he says this attitude is
legitimate but i'm persisting here and
considering a single problem in all of
its consequences in following through so
if the world really is uh
not up to to you know human beings
desires if that produces absurdity
what follows from that you can't escape
from that just by saying well that the
absurd is god is what uh camille is
saying
he says if it's admitted that the absurd
is the country of hope
it's seen that existential thought for
chester presupposes the absurd
but proves it only to dispel it it
reintroduces
hope
directly from the absurd
so here
you really have to go one way or the
other come here saying look if you have
an absurdity that rules out hope and so
if you're going to stick with the absurd
you can't turn the absurd itself into
hope
he says if there is an absurd it's in
man's universe
the moment the notion transforms itself
into eternity's springboard it ceases to
be linked to human lucidity
the absurd is no longer that evidence
that man ascertains without consenting
to it the struggle is eluded you you're
done with struggling now you have
something that you can believe that
even though it's based on the absurd man
integrates the absurd and in that
communion causes to disappear its
essential character
what is its essential character for
camus
opposition laceration and divorce
um
so he's saying look this is not going to
work he says you're sacrificing
everything to the absurd and then you're
transmuting the absurd
in the process back into what you wanted
so that now you generate a
new kind of god out there
who does satisfy human demands wishes
desires is opposed to the world
but yet somehow changes the world as
well
who else is doing this he says what is
perceptible in leo chest off will be
perhaps even more so in kierkegaard
he says kierkegaard likewise takes the
leap
and you know anyone who's read
kierkegaard
at least a superficial reading you know
that that's actually the case that
there's this distinction between
the ethical and the aesthetic and then
the religious you know and there's even
what he calls a teleological suspension
of the ethical he talks about
the need to
embrace
the absurd so you know kierkegaard is
using this this very language in this
concept
he says that kierkegaard is actually
calling for the same thing as ignatius
loyola the founder of the jesuits
interesting because loyola is like you
know sort of at that time the arch
catholic and kierkegaard is the
protestant who is too protestant for the
protestant church that he is living in
you're saying they're doing the same
thing what they demand is the sacrifice
of the intellect the sacrifice of reason
and you you simply have to say well i'm
going to believe in the absurd because
it's the absurd and god can do anything
so i'm going to
simply trust in that that would be again
what we're calling fideism in philosophy
so he says
this is kambu
between the irrational of the world
and the insurgent nostalgia of the
absurd
he doesn't maintain the equilibrium he
doesn't stay with the world and the
human being has unsatisfied
he does not respect the relationship
that pro that constitutes properly
speaking the feeling of absurdity
sure of being unable to escape the
irrational he wants at least to save
himself from that desperate nostalgia
that seems him sterile and devoid of
implication um
so
he's rejecting
um
he's rejecting all of these
what he views as theological or
religious interpretations he absurd that
end up either turning the absurd into
god or having god sort of you know
reduce absurdity in some way
and he he says something really
interesting here
at the very end we're talking about
nothing is more profound than
kierkegaard's view according to which
despair is not a fact
but a state the very state of sin
for sin is what alienates from god
here's where camus says it's something a
bit different the absurd which the met
which is the metaphysical state of the
conscious man does not lead to god
perhaps this notion will become clearer
if i risk this shocking statement
the absurd
is sin
without god
so
that's worth dwelling on
normally we think of sin
and what is sin
uh sin is is separation from god or
doing what god doesn't like or you know
a rupture or something like that for
kierkegaard it's something very profound
sin is not only you know a break between
the human being and god but also that
within the human being which keeps them
from properly recognizing that very
break
or from
you know if they recognize it from being
able to remedy it um he's getting this
you know also from people like augustine
and if you'd read saint anselm he would
have gotten this from saint anselm as
well
camilla is taking god out of the picture
so he's saying we still have that
complex of sin
we still have
the inability to come to terms with
oneself to fix oneself to make sense out
of oneself in relation to the rest of
whatever else is not the self the world
we take god out of the picture that is
the absurd for covenant
a theological conception
with the theology evacuated from it
that's one way you could think about it
so now he says i'm taking this the
liberty at this point of calling the
existential attitude philosophical
suicide why philosophical suicide
well because what's going on is
the existentialist is
carrying out philosophy so he's working
within philosophy philosophy is his life
but then he is
using philosophy to you know show that
that things don't jibe the world doesn't
work there is this absurd
between human being and the world
um but then they stop doing philosophy
as soon as that absurd becomes god
so as a philosopher they're in effect
committing suicide by ceasing to be a
philosopher they become a theologian
instead
like he says for existentials negation
is their god to be precise that god is
maintained only through the negation of
human reason
but like suicides god's change with men
there are many ways of leaping the
essential thing being to leap
and he once again stresses this is still
better than the most widespread attitude
of our enlightened age the one based on
the principle that all is reason which
aims to explain the world
but it's not going far enough he thinks
so he says our aim is to shed light upon
the step taken by the mind when starting
from a philosophy of the world's lack of
meaning
it ends up by finding a meaning and
depth in it
so
what is going to happen with this i'm
going to skip over all the discussions
about about phenomenology here
and
further discussions about kierkegaard
and reason and all that sort of stuff
because i want to get to
kaimu's own
ethics that he's elaborating
he says that the leap
we don't want to take the leap
we don't want to
jump into the absurd into the eternal
we want to hold ourselves in this
tension between the world and the human
being that is absurd he says um the
danger is not the leap
like kierkegaard would like it it's you
know it's all too easy to take the leap
the danger on the contrary lies in the
subtle instant that precedes the leap
being able to remain on that dizzying
crest as the wave is going up where you
might say okay i know i'm going to leap
that is integrity he says
so again ethical terminology integrity
and the rest is subterfuge
so
what would this be like then what would
absurd freedom what would absurd
ethics
living in the world
being
not necessarily okay but being okay
enough to stay and not make any sort of
leap out of the world
not to give way to
immature unrest not to give way to
renunciation not to give way to despair
and not to try to you know leap into the
absurd
out of the absurd
um
what would this look like what would a
existentialist ethics for an atheist
existentialist look like
so he says
what i know what is certain what i
cannot deny what i cannot reject this is
what counts
i can negate everything of that part of
me that lives on vague nostalgias accept
this desire for unity that's longing to
solve this need for clarity and cohesion
i can refute everything in this world
surrounding me that offends or
enraptures me except this chaos this
sovereign chance and this divine
equivalence which springs from anarchy i
don't know whether this world has a
meaning that transcends it but i know
that i do not know that meaning and that
it is impossible for me just now to know
it so again
if you want to think about it this way
this is a sort of cartesian starting
point what do i know what can i be
certain of
i know that i don't know the meaning of
the world and that it's impossible just
now for me to know it
so the i am certain of two things he
says i have a certainty of this appetite
for the absolute and for unity and the
impossibility
of reducing this world to a rationable
and reasonable principle i also know i
can't reconcile them so again we have
that tripartite schema of
human being
world
the absurd in the confrontation between
them
coming out again
and he says you know if i were a tree
among trees or a cat among other animals
this life would have a meaning where the
problem would not arise but it does
arise for me because i can think i can
question i can look at my world and
reflect upon it
so as soon as i start doing that it
starts to become
absurd i start to realize the disconnect
between myself and this world about
which i'm thinking in which i'm acting
about which i'm desiring
so
what should we do
well the first thing that he says
well it's not the first thing but the
first major thing that he says
says
let's insist on a method
what is the method
it's a matter of persisting
at a certain point on his path the
absurd man is tempted
history is not lacking in either
religions or prophets even without gods
he's asked to leap
jump into something
commit
and then commit and then you'll figure
out the meaning after that
it says all he can reply is that he
doesn't fully understand that it's not
obvious indeed he does not want to do
anything but what he fully understands
he is assured this is the sin of pride
but he doesn't understand the notion of
sin
an attempt is made to get him to admit
his guilt he feels innocent tell the
truth that's all he feels is irreparable
innocence this is what allows him
everything hence what he demands of
himself is to live solely with what he
knows to accommodate himself to what is
and to bring nothing in that is not
certain
he wants to find out whether it is
possible to live as he puts it
without appeal
without bringing in anything else that
you don't
actually know
it says he wants to live solely with
what he knows to accommodate himself to
what is to bring in nothing that is not
certain
so
what will this mean then
what are the implications of this
now remember what we began with
his first initial assertion there's one
philosophical problem and what is that
problem the problem of suicide it says
now i can actually approach this notion
of suicide
at this point the problem is reversed
before it was a question of finding out
this life of a meaning if life does have
a meaning then don't kill yourself if
life doesn't have a meaning well then
maybe you should kill yourself
and he says
on the contrary it will be lived all the
better if it has no meaning
living an experience a particular fate
is accepting it fully
now no one will live this fate knowing
it to be absurd unless he does
everything to keep before him that
absurd brought to light by consciousness
negating one of the terms of the
opposition on which he lives amounts to
escaping it
well what's killing yourself remember
what what is the absurd
what's the opposition human being world
you can negate the world
you can also negate the human being kill
yourself that's negating the human being
that's to try to
get rid of the absurd by taking one of
the pieces out of the
mosaic so to speak
so
he says one of the only
coherent philosophical positions
is that of trying to live in the absurd
and how do you do that
by what he calls permanent revolution
revolt
he says it's a constant confrontation
between man and his own obscurity
so metaphysical revolt extends awareness
to the whole of experience
suicide settles the absurd on the other
hand it engulfs the absurd in the same
death
so
in addition to all of this
again what else do we have
uh rejection but also
revolt
and later on
camus will write another book in which
he's going to deal with these same
themes one which we're going to analyze
uh in some other videos called the uh
the rebel in english translation that's
actually lom revolte
the
man who
has revolted the man who is revolting
the one who is is rebellious
that's part of kamu's ethic
dealing with the absurd so
living in a world of the absurd does not
mean accepting it except in the sense
that you don't try to make it go away
so he says consciousness and revolt
these rejections are the contrary of
renunciation everything that is
indomitable and passionate and a human
heart quickens them on the contrary with
its own life
it is essential to die unreconciled
not of one's own free will again you
can't just kill yourself to get yourself
out of the picture suicide is a
repudiation the absurd man can only
drain everything to the bitter end
and deplete himself
the absurd is his extreme tension which
he maintains constantly by solitary
effort for he knows that in that
consciousness in that day-to-day revolt
he gives proof of his only truth which
is what defiance
this is a first consequence he says
so then he asks so if i'm going to stay
in this position
which consists of drawing all the
conclusions
with this i'm faced with the second
paradox
in order to remain faithful to that
method you know to follow through on
things
i can have nothing to do with the
problem of metaphysical liberty he says
i'm not interested in the question of
whether man is free or not
here he's really um
you know departing from somebody like
sark right for whom human freedom is at
the very center of his
his philosophy also you know simone
bevoir
he says i have nothing to do with the
problem of metaphysical liberty knowing
whether or not man is free does not
interest me i can only experience my own
freedom i can't experience somebody
else's freedom i can't experience
freedom as such i can only experience my
own
it says i cannot understand what kind of
freedom would be given me by a higher
being
i've lost the sense of hierarchy
the only one i know is freedom of
thought and action
so now
what would this look like this absurd
freedom he says
before encountering the absurd the
everyday man lives with aims
a concern for the future for
justification
he weighs his chances he counts on
someday his retirement to the the labor
of his sons he thinks that something in
his life can be directed in truth he
acts as if he were free even if all the
facts make a point of contradicting that
liberty but after the absurd after you
actually begin to take the absurd
seriously and you decide i'm not going
to try to escape this i'm not going to
you know renounce the world or leap out
of it or anything like that
after the absurd everything is upset
the idea that i am my way of acting as
if everything has a meaning
all that is given the lie by the
absurdity of a possible death
thinking of the future establishing aims
for oneself having preferences all this
presupposes a belief in freedom even if
one
occasionally ascertains that one doesn't
feel it but at that moment i'm well
aware that higher liberty that freedom
to be which alone can serve as a basis
for truth does not exist
so you know what does this mean
well
one of the things that camus is actually
saying is the existentialist the
atheistic existentialist at least
the way that they're going to live out
the freedom that they have the only
freedom that they can truly understand
is by living day to day
does that mean they can't make any plans
at all you know if you buy a train
ticket you're in a way making a plan
aren't you
no it doesn't mean that you just can't
count on anything
you can't commit yourself there what you
can do is commit yourself to the present
so he says
um i'm going to skip over a little bit
the absurds and the absurd enlightens me
on this point there is no future
henceforth this is the reason for my
inner future my inner freedom
and he compares the absurd man to the
mystic who loses himself in some other
thing
and he says
completely turned towards death the
absurd man feels released from
everything outside the passionate
attention crystallizing it
he enjoys a freedom
from ordinary from common rules
he says it can be seen at this point
that the initial themes of existential
philosophy keep their entire value
so the
the absurd man the person who is
actually living with the absurd
they're not going to be bound by the
same rules as everybody else why because
they're absurd right what's the point in
actually sticking to them or worrying
about them
and he says another thing there's a
second consequence
the absurd man catches sight of a
burning and frigid transparent and
limited universe in which nothing is
possible but everything is given and
beyond which ev all is collapse and
nothingness he can then
decide to accept such a universe and
draw from it his strength his refusal to
hope and the unyielding evidence of a
life without consolation
so then the question is what do we do in
this case
he says what does life mean in such a
universe a universe
that's burning and frigid transparent
and limited
well he says
nothing else for the moment but
indifference to the future that doesn't
mean there's no actual future
but you have indifference towards it
indifference of the future and a desire
to use up everything that is given so
again here we see
camus does have an ethic a desire to use
up everything that is given
it says belief in the meaning of life
always implies a scale of values you can
rank order things you know this is this
is higher this is lower i should
sacrifice this for this
a choice our preferences belief in the
absurd
according to our definitions teaches the
contrary
so it says it's all on the same level
you know saving a child
is just as meaningful
and just as meaningless
as petting a dog or enjoying a cup of
coffee
the only thing that gives it meaning is
my choice to give it meaning
my choice to commit myself there my
choice to
you know engage in all these things like
struggle you know saving a child could
be a way of struggling against the
absurdity of life
so he says
knowing whether one
can or cannot live without appeal
is all that interests me
it's not up to me to wonder whether any
of this sort of thing is vulgar
revolting elegant or deplorable once and
for all value judgments are discarded
here in favor of factual judgments
all these ideas of like ordinary
morality or previous ethical theories
you know people can still use those they
can keep them but they don't have any
meaning for me he's saying
as the absurd man
this is what he has meaning for me this
is my ethics
so he says
what do i want what can i take as my
point my basis for ethics
um
the most living
so that's another key point
most
living or as he is going to call this an
ethics of
quantity
the most living in the broadest sense
that rule means nothing it calls for
definition it seems to begin with the
fact that the notion of quantity has not
been sufficiently explored he says
for it can account for a large share of
human experience
a man's rule of conduct
and a scale of values
have no meaning except through the
quantity and variety of experiences he
has been in a position to accumulate
having the most
quantity
of experiences
is going to be for camus at least in the
myth of symphysis
the basis of his ethics
the way in which he evaluates things
because you can't get away from
evaluating in one way or another i mean
he can he can talk all he likes
about um
you know
a scale of values a choice our
preferences are we're throwing all that
aside he can say you know the vulgar
revolting elegant or deplorable value
judgments for throwing all that aside
well you can't get away from all of that
altogether you have to have some way in
which you make some sort of judgment
you can't escape moral judgment
this is going to be his basis
quantity of experiences quantity and
variety of experiences so you know if
saving a child will actually provide you
with a great quantity of experience and
a variety of experience
then that would fit into that ethics
on the other hand if poisoning a child
would do that or poisoning your neighbor
would do that
that would also
seem to fit into this this is actually a
good place for us to break off at this
point you should at this point
feel
a bit
worried a bit concerned about
where camus is going with this
by the way camus is not for poisoning
anybody let alone children and he was a
you know great benevolent person who
showed a lot of kindness and sympathy
towards uh many people
the question is whether his own ethics
that he's developing here would
countenance that would jibe with that
so
this is where we'll leave off and in the
next video we'll take up
right where we're leading off with this
this ethics of quantity of experience
and look at
the different types that he
distinguishes and then talk about
creation and then finally we'll get to
the myth of synthesis itself